herzlich willkommen zu meinem heutigen
video leute ich bin ich das schon gesagt
sondern zusammen mit sebastian uhr leute
irgendwie ist das total happy und so
aber irgendwas fehlt mir was eine idee
ich habe nie die dekoration für denn
hier halt da ist mein charakter sticker
[Musik]
leute juristischer also macht man
werbung des tatsächlich das erste mal
dass ich in einem youtube-video trage
das haben wir schon viele wahrscheinlich
gesehen aber das ist mein frisches neues
merchandise am zehnten elften in meinen
store kommt übrigens das erste
merchandise seit zwei jahren ich bin
super gut gelungen ist ziemlich cool
palette details ich wollte einfach mal
gezeigt haben dass wir schon mal einen
ersten eindruck davon ab aber es gibt
noch mein eigenes video ist also was
machen wir heute wie spielen das great
language gehen
wir kriegen gleich 20 sekündige
ausschnitte von irgendeiner sprache der
welt vorgespielt und haben dann vier
auswahlmöglichkeiten aber ist schon geil
content klar was jetzt die leute lieben
das was hast du noch die leute gehen
komplett crazy die licon gerade jeder
jeder leid von denen aber wenn sie das
hier sehen dann kommentieren wir auch
nach egal was hast du da haben us import
aus frankreich haribo spicy trägt dass
irgendeine halloween special edition ihr
seht ihr hinten drauf
die sind unterschiedlich scharf je nach
farbe und wir machen es wie folgt wir
wechseln uns ab mit dem erraten von
sprachen und auf anfang verpackt man
dann ist man halt so ein harmloses also
wir werden mit der zeit besser aber die
strafen der noch härter ich würde sagen
die reden nicht weiter und heute denke
ich mache mir nicht los geht's
zu fall würde ich sagen dass es
italienisch ist weil ich spreche etwa
jene schied last für euch noch ein
bisschen weiter laufen wie ist auch
sinken lassen
der generali produktpräsentation und
umami und sebastian klick auf next
wollen diesen ungewöhnlichen eigentlich
post oder telefon bekommt das ist auf
jeden fall fährt und ich fahre diese
sogar spricht halt gute sprache bekommen
die ich ausspreche und zwar türkisch
schlägt man hätte ich nicht gewusst
also ich habe keine ahnung wo man
theologe spricht aber es klingt für mich
sehr nach einer asiatischen sprachen
es kribbelt service und verbuchte das
ist teilen leute wusstet ihr habt ihr
die sachen erkannt schreibt es in die
kommentare wer zu gewalt aufruft schon
jeweils zwei jahre gefängnis aber nur
wenn die letze für eine breite
öffentlichkeit wahrnehmbar ist das heißt
für mindestens 150 personen
künftig sollen 30 personen reichen sagt
justizminister wolfgang veranstalten die
gassen war so an für das rheinische art
ist wie jungen italienisch türkisch okay
jetzt was hattest du davor teil teilen
was soll das für eine scheiße sein ist
echt schweren das klingt nach sonne
schon also gerade dieses eine wort hier
das 150 personen
dies ist eine 150 personen bis noch
nicht zu ende
du kannst ja sprechen folglich war
vielleicht ist dann deutsch
aber ich werde keinen tipp geben also
dass für jeden fall nicht deshalb weil
österreicher muss österreich nicht
wieder rausgekommen bin ein stadtkind
räuber wirst du frist jetzt applaus laut
sehe ich glaube die blau sind okay ist
ja auch diese noch diesen ob die blauen
sind einfach nur pik und die anderen
sind halt experten dass bei steam aber
was dem picknick oder wie das wäre
schädlich da will ich mir auch erst
jetzt aktiv weil wenn ich jetzt ganz
dummen fehler ist gerade die schwedische
und deswegen ist jetzt jede und das wird
wahrscheinlich nicht wahrscheinlichkeit
aus alter ist kommt berlin ist mir auf
den extra hatten und pick gespannt sein
und so einen vertrag wie man weiß jetzt
dass nicht nur dass keiner das null
schafft nur schaffen nur sagen wir dann
einen blauen haben wir noch der wird
noch gegessen und danach wird's richtig
unangenehm
du darfst sie aber jetzt nicht zurück
also ich will dich jetzt familie mache
ich nicht beantworten die nachtruhe
steine berichtet die
schmiergeldzahlungen stellen für den
kärntner fpk das den alarm aus das ist
auch jeder camper sei aber warum kommt
zweimal hintereinander
wir können nicht irgendwie weil die ip
raus bin dass wir in deutschland ich bin
ja englisch
das ist in anderen blauen not quite
hatte wenn ich jetzt schiffsbank
broadway revival
während das original bedeutet wer wird
diese drei reiter weiß ich übrigens
fragt mich an die dinger komme ich habe
zu meinem partner schon da ist pole aus
bestellt jede bestellung kriegt ein
einzigartiges polaroid die firma durch
die bestellt habe ist in frankreich und
dadurch haben wir das einfach bei
kriegen weil die korrektion erst gar
nicht im video verwendet
klingt sehr nach französisch und
deswegen würde ich sage ich sag s
heidelpay schon weil haiti glaube ich
sehr schlank französische einfluss hat
die stadt ist voller bestimmt noch
besser und da kann man nicht drum bass
ramos karriere
diese störgeräusche haben hinten und ja
versucht das ist das im gespräch ist
manchmal einfach klare gespräch
ramonas der batterien
das klingt für mich nach einer
arabischen sprache ok also ich weiß
nicht ob
die sprache ist ne also fußweg
usbekistan nehmen das ist was ist das
nordisches beeck also im norden das 1906
entsprechende alles aus als wir jetzt
ist der wunderbaren was auch für butter
schwedisch nein
kritisch ist auch nicht hause oder ich
bin einfach gut 321 kein fall ist es
muss bild was klar ist dass die schläger
normaler reflex parierte nature dar und
schließlich wer macht das schon etwas
besonderes
das heißt verdammt nochmal und jojo
schimm du musst sie fressen und zwar die
rote scharfe und sauer erstmal geld ist
man die rote ja ich nicht weniger städte
er sieht aus wie nach barriere wie
sonova scharfen chili sabine flamme
tasse tee ich bin gespannt wann die
schärfe kommt und man das ist entwickelt
sich schon komisch ich das gefühl
trotzdem raten sie überhaupt nicht das
ist günstiger zu bekommen jetzt die
posco frische leute einen job
während wdi schaffe ist jetzt gleich mal
so also der frank rost im rest ist es
nicht so super scharf zu stellen weil
sie ist die zunge so ein bisschen taub
und wohne kann das vergleicht mit
absolut gar nichts sagen teufels ist es
so fascher oder ge chef sowie pfeffer
okay und man merkt aber so als ob du im
bettchen dabei ist passt gar nicht
zusammen was soll daran liegt dass es
ein saures google bashing ist dann
spielen wir jetzt weiter 1 haben wir
doch es geht jetzt also jetzt bin ich
jetzt bist du wirst du angst weil das
war gerade echt schon aber immer noch
das meist so im mund und wer das andere
extra scharf ist dann bin ich das echt
nicht
müssen also ja weiter geht es so weiter
geht hängt das ist was ich bekomme wenn
ich ins kisuaheli bekommst du so
verkommen ja ja auf jeden fall entweder
chinesischen datei aber immer erst mal
ganz deutlich mehr nach chinesischer
oder waren es ein paar momente da ruhig
er das so spricht er so ein teil dieses
fein haben irgendwann chinesischen über
die betonung usa
ich will ich gerecht sparen und
geldverschwendung
nein das ist für mich dass man auch klar
dass das finde ich dass es dir bist du
gut genug bist doch finish das getan
es gibt viele leute was habe ich getan
hat nicht sofort da finde ich dass die
meisten warum ich hatte das stellenweise
so ein bisschen italienisch wären euro
mensch ist ein italienischer einflüsse
so deshalb dazu ok machst du kurzen
prozess finish klingt so komplett von
dieser welt ja auch nie glaube ich
jemanden finnischen hören ich habe
verdammt leute die gleich etwas ist
damit dann bist du den kreismeister sg
s/s die rote flamme das schärfste und
haribo gummibärchen der welt titelte
tritt dann gönne ich mir das mal so
schön aus den leeren magen herzen ging
dessen noch ein kleines bisschen auch
schon vorher zu sowas sagen wie scharf
das ist dann so ist nicht so die tränen
in die augen treibt fertig natürlich
schade und jedoch kein spaß kann die
abnahme schmeckt beschreiben wir
beschreiben geschlechts sind vergessen
vater sind hat er ist ganz komisch
hetzel sind ganz ganz braver gewaltiger
wenn man den speicher unterstützt das
richtig weiter dass viele leute diese
gummibärchen sind eigentlich gar nicht
so schlechte idee für ihn bei wenn ich
kinder ab fakten und dabei nur die
scharfen dieses spiel ist übertrieben
lustig das muss ich eigentlich noch mal
so machen also so runden wird sie quasi
gegeneinander
ich hoffe dass wieder durchgefallen
falls ja das gerne leichter
max king.de rhythmisch